zéro de conduite
c'est ce que vous risquez automobilistes
inexpérimentés qui venait de passer
votre permis à l'instar de pierre dac à
la veille des vacances
apprenez d'abord à connaître votre
propre voiture et ne confondez pas le
démarreur avec n'importe quel autre
bouton ou le frein avec l'accélérateur
un démarrage plus rapide sans
signalisation zéro de conduite ou doublé
sur une route glissante et zéro de
conduite et là-bas j'enchaîne les
voitures qui semble vivre où l'école si
l'équipe on n'existait pas
zéro de conduite doublé en haut d'une
côte démarré en s'imaginant qu'il n'ya
au monde une seule voiture là contre 0
du conduite oublier qu'il existe aussi
des cyclistes et des cyclistes
imprudents ses héros de conduite ne pas
se mettre en mode éblouir d'autres
conducteurs stationnés sur la route sans
feux de position au zéro de conduite où
les avants comme on dit les pieds au
plancher ce héros de conduite
et vous de tous c zéro de conduite la
conducteurs novices aux antilles
conducteur expérimenté il vous mènera
loin au goût trop loin